it seems that whatever the Obama
administration has done it seems the
current administration wants to undo how
do you handle that when you look at the
work that you all have done the
presidencies is an arse to own you know
it's the people's job so it's I always
find it interesting when people say how
do you feel about and it's not it's not
how me and Barack feel we did our jobs
we did the best that we could do you
know the the question is how does the
country feel about what so I don't I
don't take it personally you don't you
know because we occupied that seat for
eight years and did the best that we
could do and the next president that is
voted in and gets to do the same thing
you know the question that we have to
ask as citizens and as voters what
direction do we want our country to go
in and we we saw here that when you sit
out sometimes you get what you want
sometimes you don't that's the nature of
our democracies I think it's interesting
you have that attitude because so many
other people are literally gnashing
their teeth to powder can you believe
he's trying to change content can you
believe what they're saying I mean and
you all are just saying you know that's
not our job it really is on the people
and when you look at that why do you
think Donald Trump won this election
when everybody thought there's just no
way that's going to happen if I don't
spend much time I came to the polls and
a lot of people didn't it is not
accomplished our democracy is clear it's
just sometimes people think my vote
doesn't count and that's just so wrong
you know you voting matters and the
people who go to the polls determine how
the country is going to be led the
notion that voting doesn't work that it
it's fixed no it's not
you know we saw in this midterms people
wanted the country to move in a
different direction and they came out in
record numbers and they voted and that's
how it works